wenn nicht schief geht dann wird es
demnächst ein legendäres Duett geben und
zwar Tim Bendzko mit Jürgen Drews und es
wird heißen die singenden Friseur im
Falle ich bin sehr gespannt kommentiert
mal unten was ihr davon haltet und
ansonsten schaut das fragen ob du wo es
noch mehr viel mehr Lustiges zu hören
und zu sehen gibt
die roten sind gemeine Fragen die in
Hamburg das ist wahrscheinlich genau
anders
die roten du kannst entscheiden will ich
haben sie auf jeden Fall eine gute Frage
immer wieder festgestellt wir sind viel
schwerer als die roten ich guck mal aber
die ist gemein
soll ich das Vorlesen ja warum kopierst
du den Stil von Matthias Schweighöfer du
hattest gerade schon angesprochen
seid ihr verwandt eigentlich das ist das
Ding wir sind eineiige Zwillinge
ursprünglich wurden aber bei der Geburt
getrennt was man sich quasi unterbewusst
dann einfach wieder anpasst und das
Dings die wohnen glaube ich auch nicht
so weit voneinander entfernt und das ist
glaube ich ein bisschen schwingendes
technisch beeinflussen wir uns dagegen
aber die Situation ist aber trotzdem die
dass der Herr Schweighöfer den kann ich
natürlich auch schon bevor ich mit ihm
verglichen wurde
aber ich habe ja auch seitdem erst so
richtig auf dem Schirm also bewusst kann
da nichts
kopiert sein also irgendwie
Luhmann und so weiter
Universum möchte noch eine Frage aber
gerne
zusammen gemacht hat ja da gehen wir
sehr viel Mühe mit
willst du nicht mal die Band die
singenden Friseur Unfälle gründen
das ist keine schlechte Idee also ich
könnte das mit meinem backcoating am
besten Freund Philipp zusammen machen ja
die Frisur von ihm ist halt auf jeden
Fall noch schlimmer als meine ich hatte
wirklich auch noch mal noch längere
Haare dachte immer die waren schon immer
so habe aber letztens Fotos gesehen dass
da wirklich schon mal viel schlimmer
könnte ich machen bin jetzt nicht so der
Boygroup Fan aber
irgendwann gesagt ich bin kurz davor
eine zweite Karriere als Schlagers da ja
zu starten und ich meine der passt auch
lieber Jürgen wenn du das jetzt hörst
ich habe ein Bandnamen für uns ja ähm
ich möchte aber was Ramona dann auch
dabei ja danke okay super aber das ist
ja bei Jürgen der schneidet sich ja
wirklich die Haare selbst was man nicht
sieht
so
es gab ja bessere Songs beim Bubi Soko
ja das ist auch da muss man darauf also
2010 stand da nicht das habe ich
geantwortet meine Antwort war 2010
als die von 2010 gewesen
ja Eisberg also eines der schönsten
deutschsprachige Lieder gehört haben für
die Text unglaublich gut ich finde das
schwierig den Reform so ein bisschen mit
diesem kopfstimmen und so das ist jetzt
dann
das ist glaube ich ein Jahr nee Kopf nee
also so kurz ja aber so wenn das
verlangst du schwieriger hat das krass
gesungen aber ich äh
da muss einfach da wenn er da noch mal
so richtig mit Stimme ja gekommen wäre
hätte gewonnen ja okay aber ich finde
der Text von dem Lied also wie geht's
einem Text nicht ganz wundervoll wie
erklärst du deinen Erfolg an der Musik
liegt ja nicht
es sind äh ja es ist die Ähnlichkeit zum
Herrn okay
und denken sich da kommen was der macht
ist toll die gehen auch in jedem Film
von ihm der jetzt also worum es geht
und es liegt daran okay und daran dass
meine Mutter einfach
100.000 Alben gekauft hat von einem hier
anni das habe ich alle Fragen
beantworten
oh gott du bist Tim Bendzko das ist auch
gar keinen Fall eine Frage hast aber das
ist keine Ahnung aber das ist halt dass
ein Fan steht vor dir und sagt oh gott
du bist die Bendzko
Matthias
ehrlich
unterschreibt das sage ich immer
Matthias okay das ist eigentlich
überhaupt nicht witzig aber die ganze
Zeit
ist ein bisschen wie bei der Auslosung
DFB-Pokal Bayern München gegen Schalke
04 was lässt dich die was lässt dich die
Herzen deiner weiblichen Fans brechen
da muss ich mir schon
keine Ahnung es ist hoffentlich sind
hoffentlich die Lieder die ich singe
okay alles andere wäre
was macht dich so smart
ich weiß es nicht äh keine Ahnung also
erstmal danke
einfach Selbstbewusstsein antrainiert
wahrscheinlich und das führt dazu dass
sie Smart erscheinen aber eigentlich
okay das heißt du warst ein
armer kleiner Junge der immer verprügelt
worden ist und wirklich also ich war mit
also 18 Jahren also derart schüchtern da
hatte ich so so als Model gearbeitet
jetzt kommt raus und das Ding ist also
wirklich ich kam das zu diesem
Fotoshooting und habe es geschafft den
ganzen Tag mit niemand ein Wort zu
wechseln weil ich mir so in die Hose
gemacht habe weil ich das alles so
kannte die alle nicht und wie hast du
ich darf ja nicht ansprechen das Mädchen
kennengelernt mit dem öfter zu tun hast
das musst du sie fahren ich kann mich
nicht mehr erinnern ich war da betrunken
nein
selbst also sie wird sie auch nicht
erzählen weil das so unangenehm ist dass
wir das nicht erzählen
okay vielleicht mit Sido wir haben das
war irgendwas
und er hat vorne gesessen und gekifft
und sie waren das total scheiße
das ist ja meistens bei Frauen und
Männern so der Einstieg das
einfach weiß wie man sich streiten würde
und das irgendwie witzig ist dann wird
der Rest auch gut bestimmt und das Ding
ist ja quasi neben meiner alten Wohnung
und jetzt 150 m Luftlinie von mir
entfernt naja okay
gut ich wünsche dir dass dieses Unglück
nicht passiert und
hätte ich komplett dabei ist ja